yeah okay
we carry the Zipit instantly I know
patience is the key put enough on my
ship for free this is t we carry feet
michael make the friend good morning
good good morning for 21 a wonderful
Tuesday in April we are now fully in it
and we are fully into teatime
the tea is in the building and we are
fully into this quarantine and covin and
things that nature and I hope
everybody's families are super well and
doing as best as they can and I thought
yes there was a monster of an episode
and let's see if we can get an hour's
worth of great stuff today so first and
foremost like always please take a
screenshot of this right now and share
it on your Twitter and if you're
watching on Facebook hit the reshare
button that would be amazing and if
you're on youtube tweet out that and
let's get some awareness going share
with your facebook group let's have a
great show Dustin thank you for being on
the ones and twos again and let's just
get right into it Heidi there you go hi
yes how are things it's ok you know it's
really weird I think I'm seeing things
right now because of the whole
quarantine thing but I know we don't
have a lot of times so I just want to
get into it um obviously being a big fan
of yours for years and I know you've
worked with a lot of entrepreneurs
you've you've you know mentor consulted
and give you know tough love to a lot of
entrepreneurs I guess my question would
be from your experience talking to a lot
of entrepreneurs what do you think if
this is valid is um the number one thing
that you notice is holding back a lot of
female entrepreneurs specifically as
opposed to just you know male
entrepreneurs you know the truth is I
don't see you know I interact with
obviously a lot of men and women and
income levels racist you know there's
always nuances you know obviously you
know insecurity is always
and and and judgment is always an
incredible driver but like plenty of
white males that grew up in America have
massive insecurities because their moms
or dads implemented it so you know I
think that sure there's thematics you
know here I hear constantly the excuse
of like well Gary I have to look good to
make a video from them and you know like
men say they've got a like look the part
or otherwise they won't be respected
like you hear certain things but the
truth is it's pretty universal it's it's
people want things too fast they
actually don't love their business they
love money from a business to buy things
they want that destroys entrepreneurs
cuz there's because they're not
entrepreneurs they're in it right now
because it became the thing no different
those same people 20 years ago would
have been doctors and lawyers and
dentists and architects or whatever the
money brought to it what has happened
with entrepreneurship over the last half
decade is you know people think that's
where the money is and so you have a lot
of people going into it who don't love
it a phenomenon that became obvious to
me and when I got into a veiner Vayner
sports so many athletes actually don't
love theirs yeah it's the place where
they can make the most money so yeah you
know I think it's I think it's
insecurity or it's complete and utter
addiction to buying things or having
said and then it leads to insecurity
great because having a big car having a
nice clothes having a big house having
that car that everybody thinks is cool
or or flexing on a picture of the nice
vacation you're on oftentimes is just
another indicator to insecure me that
you they you need outside validation to
you know drive your happiness and you're
not able to deal with you know criticism
and then and then now what you're gonna
see is a lot of entrepreneurs really
fail because they just really didn't
actually know how to run a business it
was really you know their their
economics were upside down they they
didn't save they didn't make assumptions
they didn't strategize and so that's
something to think about okay and then
my last question would be you know just
that going off that is you know talking
about insecurity how you know I deal of
a lot of people and myself I suffer from
insecurity sometimes like how do you
when you're when you're faced with that
you know I have a lot of clients or
colleagues they're insecure and I can't
come across it's really strong how do
you like make sure that day on this you
know like be aware of that and don't get
defensive but that's my number one thing
we're just working with people like they
get super defensive and then they just
act it stacked it's why I think I do
what I do well like you know it's it's
delivering its delivering you know I
think most people that are can Duras
don't know how to deliver it with sugar
okay give some sugar yeah of course
the reason this all works and this show
works and I work is because I'm coming
from a place of compassion and love and
empathy and legacy which leads to sugar
most people when they give radical
candor or shoot it straight are actually
coming from a selfish place they're
giving they're giving radical candor
that they hope they spend more money
with them or you know like they're
coming from a selfish place yeah so how
do you make people not be defensive come
from a place of love and selflessness
humans are animals they sense things a
lot of people think they can just be a
bull in a china shop and that might work
for a little while but long term that is
not a sustainable model and you will
lose your audience mm-hmm yeah I've seen
you do it many times like you just dive
in but I can tell like you also tell
them like what would work and you also
give that moksha niacin so I can it's
yeah thank you so much take care
yourself
bye bye fight let's keep it going Dustin
what's good bro you're on there we go
Cole your honor okay
how are you uh good you I'm well yes so
if you don't mind I can go ahead and
jump right into what I wondered ass
custody today so I'm a sophomore in high
school who I live in West Houston and
I've always been interested in the
entrepreneurial scene and what you know
what you've been able to contribute to
it starting small business has always
been something that's in the back of my
mind but it's never was something acted
upon but just recently with a large
amount of free time of be given due to
this corona virus outbreak I decided to
take advantage of it I decided to take
your advice stop saying no and start
saying yes so just recently I created my
own power
now the only precautions I've taken so
far to expand upon the creation of my
business is through the distribution of
flyers
door-to-door throughout my neighborhood
and through word-of-mouth
so my question for you today mr.
Vaynerchuk is how how do I turn a laptop
a printer and a serious amount of work
ethic into a business for someone on my
age a business that I can not only
create money but a large amount of
knowledge from so first step one you
never call me mr. leadership cuz I
completely shut down
definitely call me Gary I'm kidding I'm
kidding coke alright
so Colt listen I think I think a couple
things so the reality is you have a huge
advantage number one by a country mile
for your business since it's a local
business is Facebook ads you know like
you know I love the flyer hustle it's
really ironic one of my first hustles
from Wine Library was a flyer to I
barely used the computer that my parents
bought me in late high school at the
time but like one of the things I did
was print out a 20% off coupon for Wine
Library and literally go to cars in the
Short Hills Mall and put them on their
window sill so I loved that hustle but
far but if Facebook existed I wouldn't
have had to do that and that's what I
actually want you to do I want you to
really focus on on Facebook Ads
you can run them on a you know on a
5-mile radius you know three mile radius
and the key to Facebook Ads
is you're gonna go with people that live
in your area people that are of a
certain income or some other target that
lets you go to people that could afford
what you're trying to sell and then the
real key is you need to make twenty-five
to fifty different pictures and videos
and find which one leads to the most
phone calls or emails and then cut out
the 22 don't do well and keep running
the three that do well but Facebook Ads
cult will completely dominate for you
okay every local service business if
you're watching right now and you're a
landscaper if you're a pet you know want
to go to people's snow shovel er if you
if you know anything that's super local
pizza shop a restaurant Facebook ads are
by far the best play to go it will
explode I predict I mean a you have to
have the $500
to be able to run the ads do you right
now all right now I have about three
hundred to work with awesome so you need
to take your Kansas City Royals shirt
take it off your back put it on Etsy and
sell it for 19 bucks
you need to literally go in your room
right now I'm being dead serious by the
way you need to go in your attic garage
basement or your room whatever you have
you need to sell everything you own that
you don't like anymore and then you need
to figure out if anybody in your family
is willing to give up other things that
they don't use anymore and you need to
go ham on Facebook marketplace
Craigslist eBay offer up all that you
need to convert that into a thousand
dollars and then you need to run these
Facebook ads and I have a feeling your
business will have a real shot all right
well thank you so much do you have stuff
to sell yes a ton a ton I'm telling you
right now bro Colt the number one thing
that I know is every [ __ ] person
that's watching this show right now
ninety two percent have a thousand
dollars laying around their house a
thousand and people come from lote even
people with look like this is a
capitalist country even people that
aren't bracketed in the lower income
they buy [ __ ] you should have seen what
happened this week on e-commerce
everybody got their stimulus check up
twelve hundred bucks and they [ __ ]
wasted that [ __ ] this is a capitalistic
buy [ __ ] country so almost everybody
watching almost everybody obviously
there's some homeless sub there's a real
poverty line obviously there's some
frugal smart people that have a budget
but the far majority of people right now
in their closet basement living room
have ungodly amounts of [ __ ] that they
don't use anymore that they don't care
about and if they convert that to
flipping a you'll learn how to market on
eBay Facebook marketplace and Craigslist
which will then help you market your
powerwash company and you're gonna have
three hunt you're gonna have nine
hundred eighty seven dollars instead of
three hundred bucks and you're gonna
waste your first hundred two hundred
dollars on Facebook so you don't know if
the [ __ ] you're doing and that's what we
need got it yep sounds good thank you so
much good luck oh all right here we go
let's go
Katie how are you what's up Gary I love
your shirt I work for you I know you
like it
I do love it how are you well good I
hope you I have a question for you it's
really about I'm thinking about passion
and I'm thinking about how passion is
often are I feel like a sign of passion
is when you see the whole world through
that thing that you're doing like you
can understand people you understand the
world through that and so you talk about
your love of the game and I I want to
know what that really is for you like I
want to go I want you to go underneath
that like what like what is the game for
you actually one second I'll be right
back
I'll help reduce the awkwardness by
saying nothing important
I'm just drinking my tea all right sorry
about that I have to get my mom set up
properly so trying to figure out all
right what is the game for me I
apologize I mean you're you're clearly
um I believe I am you like oh yeah
genuinely like what I do you know like
like the game for me is like like I'd
rather be building businesses I'd rather
be doing this right now then something
else okay like it's it's it's almost
this crazy liberating thing where it's
like what if you could just do whatever
you wanted Katie you know like what
would you do and I don't I think most
people put work into this place of like
this is a requirement to do what I want
to do yeah
and for me it's just what I've always
wanted to do it's why I struggled so
much in school like all I would do is
daydream about starting a business or
and I'm talking about third grade fourth
grade fifth grade like I can't wait to
get home and do this idea or I can't
wait to tell Robbie and Marissa we're
gonna do this you know or like you know
like you know we're and when baseball
cards hit me that was game over then it
was so much to learn you know like and
memorize them and then wine it's just
always like the interest you know mm-hm
so so for you it's it's just about
presidents like it's about enjoying
yourself in every moment where yeah it's
what you know I yeah like I like every
part of it you know it's kind of like
when I see those athletes you know it's
why associated with rest in peace Kobe
Bryant so much hi Jen ually could see
from afar that he loved practice and
yeah he having injuries as much as he
did scoring 82 points in a game I
understand that I enjoy last night 9:40
p.m. being in a meeting trying to find
costs to save to save jobs at
vaynermedia which is a devastate you're
literally talking about okay we have to
do this Gore Suzie Magoo might have to
be let go and I know Suzie Magoo I know
her mom has got not cancer I know that
you know and so like these are dead
stating difficulties of being an
executive and a leader during these
times yet I love that challenge even
though that's not fun it's much more fun
when the world is not melting when you
aren't dealing with liquidity issues in
the global economy
when you don't have to make those
decisions much more fun you know but at
the same token I'm up for that challenge
I do enjoy that just like it's not fun
rehabbing you know broken arm but if you
love it if you [ __ ] to actually love
it if you you know all of it all of it
and and to me the stress and the
accolades being on the front page of a
of inc magazine or being in a meeting
last night at 9:40 you know seven 14
hours into your day making tough
decisions leading a group of other
leaders who are probably wanna be off
the zoom because it's 9:40 at night
already you know what I mean who are you
know finding themselves working more not
less going this time you know that's
that's real [ __ ] and so to me that's
loving my game people love
entrepreneurship when it's convenient
people love being you know a lawyer when
they litigate but not when they you know
are behind the scene like and when
you're that you're vulnerable because
then you're not completely fully
succumbed to that love that process
that's so that's what I mean when I talk
about loving my game every part of it
not just the parts that are convenient
not just the parts that bring me what I
want people are like I'm telling you the
far majority of entrepreneurs that
position themselves right now because
I've watched my whole life like they
love what entrepreneurship does for
their clout for their credit for the
potential of the boat they can buy with
it they don't love it yeah so in those
moments like I feel like people are
becoming entrepreneurs because they have
a thing that they want to do right but
but doing a thing yeah doing a thing you
could do a thing without having all the
baggage that comes with being an
entrepreneur right or or it could be a
side hustle or it could be a nonprofit
or it or you could be the number two to
somebody who's already doing it in a way
that you admire and is incredible but it
but or or you could have the humility to
do it exactly how you want it's
or thing but you just might make 49
thousand a year some of the most
successful entrepreneurs I know make 49
thousand a year
it's cuz they love honey they have four
B things in the backyard
they hand packaged it they sell it for
seventy one thousand a year with a ton
of profit so they make forty nine
thousand and they're happiest [ __ ]
they're just not [ __ ] living their
life with an Escalade and biggest nights
and private jets and and and and that I
admire way more than the people that are
making pretend they're living that life
yeah yeah you suck you see where I'm
going like when people like well Bagheri
I have to see my vision through I'm like
amazing you could be an entrepreneur see
your vision through but let's talk about
the financial part because you're
overlaying that you need to also be a
millionaire and you're a passion and
your idea and your ability is your
ability as an artist and a thinker is
high but as a business operator to make
a million dollars with it because guess
what Katie if I started [ __ ] honey
company it would do 10 million dollars
right because I have the operations and
marketing and and all those HR and all
the variables that lead to that I just
want people to be happy making forty
nine thousand with their passion and
loving all the process because I can
tell you one thing I wouldn't love I
wouldn't love jarring up the honey right
okay so that's I mean that's kind of my
question but I can make 10 million and
afford to pay somebody to do it yeah I
did my own social media all you [ __ ]
they're like oh you've got a team [ __ ]
you I did my own social media for eight
years without anybody on my team cuz I
love it which made me the best at it
which don't let me be able to afford to
hire it which then be able abled me to
be able to judge if somebody was good at
it cuz I [ __ ] did it first yeah so so
that's where the patience kind of seems
to come in right like you have to be to
make the jump to make the jump
that's why patience is so huge because
everybody who's struggling with what I'm
just talking about right now if they
thought about 15 year terms instead of
15 week terms they would get excited
about doing it it would also put
pressure on you to say do you actually
love this or you trying to make a quick
buck yeah awesome
thank you awesome thanks Gary take care
all right let me say hello to some
people I [ __ ] love this guy I love you
too :
crystal maze we are hoppin marked Robin
it is on her shirt big shout-out to
everybody on YouTube I see you all I see
you all YouTube those comments flying
and heavy let's keep it going
Gary Gary can you hear me I can Jeffrey
well first of all a virtual knuckle bump
me to you he's doing a great job
thank you very much appreciate that my
question is about strategy and at the
end of the question I've got two things
I want to give you and one thing I want
to ask and return so so first of all
strategy I've been independent guy I'm
55 years old career working for
technology companies five years ago the
company was sold I was left holding a
big bag of zero and so I went out on my
own and the I been doing okay in five
years built the business up low six
figures me and a few contractors when I
needed them so it's been doing really
well now kovat has happened to all of us
business is off more than 60% I'm sure
you can live with that but it's given me
I survived 2000 2001 when it was the
dot-com bubble burst
followed by 9/11 which totally took me
out of totally wasted me to ashes right
so me and my beautiful wife we were
prepared for this you know because we
were we're always prepared for this
right so I mean I'm in a good spot okay
so that said Jeff my apologies for
interrupting it's probably the thing I'm
most excited about out of all the
horrible things with this situation the
thing that I'm most excited about is in
2000-2001 you know and I and I lived
without ear as well with a double punch
of the dot-com burst in April and then
9/11 you learned and so you changed your
behavior we're gonna have an enormous
group of under 30 year olds that just
learned that their influence or business
or this business or that business so
that is something I'm glad you brought
that up and that's something I
definitely think is gonna be a help even
though they don't know it yet because it
hurts to start over but keep going well
yeah and they use add on that you know
all the people listening this is going
to happening something that's going to
happen again in your lifetime so you'll
learn learn the lesson multiple times
and move on so I'm gonna move here
because I got the long guys who are
being very inconvenient
don't worry all right so so
strategically what I did I've taken
pause and I'm looking back at my the
work I've been doing
and it won't surprise you this but I
found that 20% of the work that I was
doing was high paying super interesting
work that was just thrilling and used
every bit of what is me that's an 80% of
it was low paying customers were kind of
difficult to work with and it was rote
and I was just it got boring so what I'm
talking about doing for myself let me
give an example that you know because
when you start you take every job when
you're starting your business you say no
of course I think yes to everything and
then you start to weed off right and you
and how you weed off is a really
interesting strategy you know do you
command a you know line in the sand of a
substantial growth in revenue you know I
always I always say say yes to
everything up front and then when you're
at the maturity to say no before you say
no you make an offer that they probably
have to refuse by saying hey it's been
very nice our contracts up I need double
to keep going and what will people find
is that half not half ten to fifteen
percent will actually double up which is
a nice thing right well you know and one
thing I found out that one customer and
this this totally surprised me my
biggest surprise in year number three
I fired my first customer I said just
puts the wrong fit I obviously I'm not
right for you and I've never thought I
would ever do that but my point being is
this is that I want to did I want to
have more of that 20% of the work and
less of the 80 percent of that work from
from the past life and so right now I'm
down 60% or more I can't hurt my
business you know I'm saying so so what
I'm thinking is using this is the
opportunity to reposition my brand and
not eliminate the the easier smaller
lower paying work but I want to
emphasize and it's a load up you gotta
Geoffrey you're you're you know maturity
and and skills and and learnings are
there you're not gonna fire them you're
just gonna spend a hundred percent of
your time getting more of that 20
percent and over time that amortizes out
and then then you'll have the leverage
to cut that off but that's exactly right
perfect I like that now I've got two
things for you the two things they have
for you first is the the
all in challenge they won't let me by I
live in Puerto Rico and they have they
have their delivery settings yet so that
they won't deliver to Puerto Rico I
think I think that's based on the
auction and and sweepstakes rules in
America of what we can and can't take so
let me look into that or you have to use
a surrogate like I've seen a lot of
people do so thank you for bringing that
up the next thing is you know I know the
number five yes important to you yes
very important right did you know that
Latin Roman numerals the number five is
the letter V I sure do okay I also know
I also know that my son's name is Xander
with an X and my nickname for him is 15
because he has XV so perfect nice job
nice job and then if I could ask Li one
more thing if you so generous one more
thing if you would just started up to
rebrand myself I started a podcast
called the Jeff effect if you would just
say in any way you want to this is Gary
fee
welcome to the Jeff effect you got it
everybody it's gary vaynerchuk and
you're listening to the Jeff effect stay
well about yours Cheers
let's keep it going I like Jeff's fake
Jab Jab Jab right hook let me give you
two things that are just okay and you
let me give and can I get in return
something that's monstrous I'd like the
hustled yeah that's why I gave it to you
let's keep it going hey Gary
hey good morning man I'm a big fan from
Mexico nice meeting you
thank you that Katie call it me really
hard and it kind of makes like sense
about my question yesterday you were
talking to a guy called Kevin aloud he
didn't want his son to choose like a
career that he's not passionate about
and my question is how do you know when
to change careers like because I might
anytime you debate it you already know
you already know the fact that you asked
me the question I
tell you firmly that you should yeah but
the thing is that I want to be a hundred
percent sure you know like I you are a
hundred percent sure it's the question
you decided to ask me okay you're scared
you're worried about the ramifications
financially but you're a hundred percent
sure yeah like I know for a fact what
I'm passionate about
I know for a fact what is my purpose in
life I know what I want to do but the
thing is well I chose no I chose well
I'm a medical student I I chose medicine
because like it was a good thing like
your parents wanted you to or you also
are conservative and thought it was the
right thing to do well my first my
parents obviously liked the idea but I
am very very passionate about health but
I don't know if medicine is actually
like leading me to where I want to be
you know so what do you what do you so
are you still a medical student or you
practice yes I'm I'm a medical student
currently and how are you are you in
debt or your parents paying for the
school or how does Mexico work they
they're actually very supportive parents
they have always paid for my tuition my
my rent my food everything so do you
feel guilt bailing now I don't want to
disappoint them
of course well what about you telling
them that you'll pay them back after you
make it in 13 years that's kind of the
idea Wow that's I think that's huge
accountability and I think that's a
really interesting thing and by the way
based on your parents already being in a
place where they've done what based on
your vibes I almost think there's a 80%
chance they won't take it when that time
comes and it'll be and there's probably
a hundred percent chance that you'll
want to give it to them when that time
comes now the question is do you
actually believe in yourself I do
believe in myself I actually then I have
your answer you should change courses
now you should count up how much you
Oh in what they've paid for and you
should tell them that one day you'll pay
them back then you'll be happy and then
you'll be a man standing on your own two
feet and you'll be pumped you know I was
hoping before the show that you will say
that so we won yeah I know
like I always hear your you show sound
obviously you always talk about passion
and that Katy Cole actually hit me right
happy listening
they've had passion legacy destiny kind
of like it all comes down to one thing
life is actually remarkably simple good
bad light dark positive negative
everybody everybody makes everything so
complicated perfection one hundred
percent sure other people's opinions
resentment dwelling thinking they can go
into a time machine and fix something it
is only going forward in his only
positivity it is only light it is only
make yourself happy and you know what
you know you going now changing course
and paying them back even the offer of
you paying it back is something your
parents are to be so proud of however
that conversation works out whether you
do or you don't you're gonna be and on
your way and there's no there's no
there's no the greatest strength is to
change your mind my god
how you have lady they'll up sense it
takes courage to change your mind okay
you have new data to change your mind
you were [ __ ] child when you decided
to go into medicine yeah you now have
the understanding that you don't like it
as much changing your mind is the most
powerful thing in the world and people
are petrified of it because they're
worried about the judgement because of
the story that they've created for their
circle that now they're changing it
because they talked a big game or people
will think I wasn't capable I quit on
[ __ ] all the time that I'm more than
capable of doing I just don't want to do
it yeah that's totally you think like I
I truly no I can't
and everything but brother I truly know
that I probably could have gotten decent
grades I just didn't want to yeah yeah
and that's actually happened me to me
right now like I should be studying for
finals but I'm actually watching every
pot I mean every video of yours and
because you don't want to do it and I
promise you if you were working out your
healthy food brand if you were working
on your fitness program that you were
gonna sell you would be watching me for
tactics not for escapism your wizardry
Rishi bro
Chucky see you bye thank you feeling a
man this [ __ ] show
Dustin yes sir we're gonna have to
figure out how to continue the show post
Kovac right like I've been thinking
about it for sure like one letter B TV
iconic very you know askgaryvee show
pretty epic was the transition to this
new version of me daily daily view was
such an incredible new concept it
created the d-roc phenomenon straight up
that's like a true legacy nobody was
following anybody with camera before but
this is truly helping people yeah like
that's such a good point like I feel
like before I was at a nine and I feel
like this is a 10 good night but what
I'm worried about is how do i you know
my day-to-day life like how do i I'm
gonna have to really work on myself to
feel safe because what's happening here
it's more about me I don't feel anxious
about the time frame whereas whereas
what I do askgaryvee or the podcast I
know they have to be out I have to be
out you know I shouldn't I've got to
figure maybe this is the morning maybe
there's so you know what's funny you
know how I always said we have to do
these things at night because then I go
home on the back end I almost wonder if
the mornings better because I know
subconsciously I have my whole day to
catch up on anything that got [ __ ] up
that just hit me I don't know if that
makes sense to you then
I could start at least a 50 million
dollar direct-to-consumer tea business
on the back of this which wine text get
into Destin the quantex calm it is time
for my daily commercial for my dad's
wine text calm you know two days ago a
lot of people sign up yeah the last time
a beer there's not as many so I'm very
disappointed so I'm gonna go hard
because I don't want Brandon to make fun
of me then nobody signed up from tea if
this is very simple if you buy wine
if you buy wine at all more than two
times a month simple this is a simple
thing if you buy wine if you drink a
bottle of wine more than two times a
month
please go sign up to wine Tech's right
now it is literally the single best
service in the industry right now you
get you takes two minutes to sign up two
seconds to order you literally get a
text every day with the deal today's
this insane $25 infidel you know fifteen
sixteen bucks like like like there was
an $80 yesterday it was a $43 cab that
we sold for $19 and change flew out in
27 minutes it is literally the best it
is literally the best please unsubscribe
from your [ __ ] wine clubs
please stop buying from other services
the other day emails stopped going to
your local stores or supermarkets no
Costco's Trader Joe's if I brought you
any value it would mean the world to me
if you signed up for wine Tex calm if
you just signed up for wine text icon
please leave a comment in here yes Robin
the wines do sell out fast and if you're
not a wine drinker just take a
one-second pause and take wine tax calm
and post in your Facebook post or your
Facebook post especially or Twitter it
would mean a lot to me
Mindy there is free shipping on 12
bottled or durs but it's six dollars
flat so if you order six bucks six
bottles it's a dollar a bottle shipping
or or if you order three bottles just
two dollars a bottle shipping and when
you're having the savings that we're
putting and these are ridiculous deals
we spend we got five full time people
just buying trying to get the best deals
it is remarkable it is the best there's
a bunch of deal the day email services
and apps and email newsletters from good
wine stores I'm telling you this is a
hundred times better please add it to
your repertoire it would mean mean mean
the absolute world to me Thank You
Michelle
signing up thank you thank you thank you
Ross for it is ridiculous wine it's been
huge it's been huge means a lot to me so
alright let's keep going uline not a lot
of kosher wines maybe two or three times
a year
call this crazy you Warren Buffett my
dad are like my go-to guys right here I
get my dad to sign up for you because he
drinks like two bottles not two bottles
two glasses of wine like every night oh
I want your [ __ ] dad on wine texts
that is a huge requirement oh I'll get
him on for you that's Frankie Lymon I'm
on Long Island so new uniforms he's in
here tell he's got ripped off and he
needs to be on one text good
gasps yeah I got you so I like good I've
like a lot of passions and strong
interests like I've always loved
investing in stocks cryptocurrency
recently I just got like my drone
license I was gonna work this summer for
my bartender who started like a real
estate like you fly drones around you
took pictures of the houses and stuff I
just signed up for a drop shipping
Shopify course which to be honest like
I've learned more from that than a full
year of college this year so it's like I
don't know if that's a good thing or a
bad thing
oh it's a bad thing brother that's a bad
thing yes a very bad thing cuz you or
your parents or the state paid for that
college how'd you get yeah yeah it's
about education is the greatest thing on
earth being educated being more woke
being more thoughtful spiritually
informational e it's the greatest thing
on earth yeah of course was like it was
like 300 bucks and I've learned more
like way more from that than a year of
college but yeah but the way we
currently package education in America
and how we charge and how we don't let
people but we literally let people run
scams and file bankruptcy and get it off
the debt and we don't let people get
their college tuition off their debt on
bankruptcy it is the literal [ __ ]
racket yeah now for 23 to 30 7% of
people today in the medical field legal
it still is complete requirement that
piece of paper but [ __ ] me it's broken
bro yeah it definitely
is um then like I started up the
tick-tock I'm doing like this Chinese
like yo-yo thing which I've never seen
like no one's doing that
I'm tick-tock obviously you're creative
I'm creative kid I like it yeah so my
question is just like I feel like I'm
kind of all over the map with everything
like should I like double down on one
thing I like get rid of something else
no I'm a big let me rephrase everyone's
different but based on what I'm hearing
no I'll tell you why it's a huge
advantage at this young of an age to
taste a lot of things okay yeah I
definitely love like just trying new
smells well I still do it yeah empathy
Vayner Vayner X is now crazy it's not
just vaynermedia
it's the Sasha group for small
businesses it's the gallery media group
137 p.m. and peer Wow for publishing
there's Vayner speaking I have a
speaking Bureau we have tracer a
business intelligence data media
analyzation SAS business we have we have
we have something we're announcing next
week that's very close to what you're
talking about with drop shipping so you
know it's a it's something that I I love
doing all these different things some
people are just that creative and
operational some people have a lot of
things and don't operate any of them
right so there's this great saying in
the NFL if you have two quarterbacks you
have none right so I think about that in
business I'm able to focus on one core
thing vaynermedia which then allows me
to have the Gary Vee brand it allows me
to have all the Vayner X companies it
allows me to have empathy it allows me
to help my dad with wine techs it allows
me to stab 50 people against the all-in
challenge by the way have you seen Aaron
challenge yet yes it's amazing it's one
of you came out with that all by
yourself
no actually Michael Rubin the founder of
fanatics which is incredible ecommerce
and he's an amazing entrepreneur he came
up with the idea I brought in his friend
Alan Tisch to deal with him a couple
days later they're like [ __ ] we need to
explore this let's bring in Gary but
we've done a lot of the marketing and
I've gotten a lot of beer is such a good
idea
all right better way to raise money my
eyes dude the raffle tickets are 10
bucks some of that stuff you need to
really amped you need to put 40 bucks
into that try to win oh yeah anyway um
yeah bro I think you keep tasting based
on what I'm hearing all right so just
dad was like you want to honestly know
if I was your older brother I'd actually
say to you yo bro
do three more things okay like
definitely and I'm just stuck in my
house like I can't do anything so
there's nothing better to do then
nothing now take two shopsite courses
and learn stuff Lauren had a new content
on LinkedIn that's a little fun fact
play with that all right oh good my
other thing was like you always talk
about like loving the game which I
definitely do like I love doing all the
stuff but I also like my top I also like
a lot of money to like not not to spend
money like I just love saving money
that's good man that means you I mean
Cole you're going to be successful it is
very likely that if you love the idea of
amassing money and you love being
creative and like the grind you get
you've been gifted with some real DNA
like that's good like like there's
nothing wrong with amassing and saving
money using money to buy things to hide
behind your to your actual and happiness
that's what you're concerned about you
saving money people buying a Lamborghini
because they actually know what that is
like and they love that feeling and
they're not using it to front and they
can afford it the greatest thing in the
world somebody buying a Lamborghini on
credit they can't afford because they
want to get the girl and they think they
need that or they got picked on or like
they actually don't like themselves
because their parents did a bad job
that's what I'm trying to fight against
gosh you got actually uh the last thing
you don't have to watch it but I made
there's like a new a new trend on
tick-tock whatever's like how's my for
whatever at the end where you're
supposed to like target like it specific
like group of people or person so I made
one about you I love I hit up yours
wanna watch there anything yeah what's
your uh what's your tick-tock account
it's coal and then Cornell no spaces
just spell like Co le cornell like the
college to else that's the other thing
man you have like a epic name you're
like set call like hold Cornell is like
a proper [ __ ] name for success thank
you pork focus on happiness all the
other [ __ ] you were gifted I'm telling
you alright awesome just focus on
happiness bro stay quiet in your head
that's how it gets good thank you so
much brother it's awesome you got a call
good show so far hi Linda hi Gary oh my
gosh I just listening to you this
morning thank you
um and my but oh yeah I heard about you
yeah I just I got up this morning I know
it's gonna be on I supposed to be on
yesterday you know like all right and
just like hide you like that I was just
oh I haven't listened to all of it I'm
about 40 minutes in it's amazing just
just just thank you I'm just just so
honored oh my god just like I'm getting
all emotional but um just I heard um the
reason I call for one is just want just
to thank you for everything you're doing
second you had dr. Mark Hyman
I know sure while ago and I was just
like oh my gosh that's me that's me I'm
like the female version of him just like
you know trying to tell people you gotta
take care of your house ma'am that's
like everything because without this
it's just like you can't do anything in
life and like right now I feel like it's
like the perfect time that like my
business should be thriving I love what
I do I've gone out again the speaking
thing I worked for a nutrition company
actually going out speaking getting free
seminars you know and I do all that I do
ebooks I have YouTube videos telling
people how to do things I'm doing the
jab jab and just give me giving giving
them like why maybe not thriving
thriving financially yeah are you asking
for money oh yeah yeah yeah I have a I
have a practice and I mean right now
I've been doing a lot of video chats are
you do you think you're good at the ask
or does it come easier for you to do the
give it doesn't care it doesn't come
easy
yeah listen it's super funny did you
ever did you ever read my book Jab Jab
Jab right hook I haven't I just I've
heard a lot about okay Dustin Dustin as
soon as I sober connect with Linda and
send her a copy let's get my publisher
to send her a copy of Jab Jab Jab right
hook
classic so Linda I'm gonna send you a
copy you're well
I want you to read it it's funny when I
wrote it and the concepts for everybody
who doesn't know because I wrote it
several years ago seven or eight years
ago now I think it's you know Gib Gib
Gib and then ask write to many people at
the time on the Internet I'm just asking
everything was sale sell sign up for my
course sign up for my zoom sign up for
my you know lesson my coaching and I it
was disgusting and it was just not
working and I was like [ __ ] I gotta help
the world I'm gonna tell them how I'm
doing it which is Gib Gib Gib and then
ask so for example you you just saw and
you've been watching me bTW like I'm
really asking people to sign up for my
dad's wine tech service because I love
my dad a lot and its really a good
service and I really am happy about it
it works for both ends like anybody who
buys wine there's gonna save money and
get better wine and my dad's gonna be
pumped you would be shocked Linda how
many people are watching right now buy
wine all the time and still have not
signed up and have gotten ungodly
amounts of value for me right now right
now they're watching and literally that
just hit them right in their chest yeah
cuz like [ __ ] really I really didn't
take the two minutes to sign up and do
this forget like that's true so it it
you have to understand it's not take
when you give it's ask a couple things
when I wrote it I thought I was doing it
for all the people that were just
spamming all the time what I realized
when I got the feedback was the people
that got the most out of it were you the
people that weren't good at asking
because when they asked they were half
pregnant they weren't with conviction
they weren't straight and they weren't
like it was just like convoluted because
it didn't come easy to that yeah yeah I
get that too because it's like I feel
like I twelve so my husband yesterday
I'm like I feel like I'm the Gary Vee
when it comes to like health and
wellness you know because it's just like
if somebody comes in and they have an
issue I'll look at their blood work
they've been to all these doctors and
it's like damn Bam Bam Bam Bam I figure
things out I'm like okay it's this this
this is we're gonna do and everything
you do is natural and drug lists so it's
just like I feel like man I'm so good at
this I should have like tons of you know
how do you how do you end up clients you
have a big email list you have a big
email list a big so really I mean maybe
fifteen hundred like I said I do I have
videos but I mean I have maybe how do
you ask almost like how do you go in for
the ask how do you do it no usually you
like I do free like I give away free
ebooks but I also have on my website
like a free 15 minute phone consult to
see if I can help them how does that
then I am did a lot of 15mm yes and no
and maybe 90% our conversion but lately
I haven't and usually those that do
because everything is consummated people
follow how many people follow you on and
Surin probably about 500 or so a lot of
folks okay how many emails do you have
um probably about 1500 on my list okay
you should send an email today and say I
would like all of you to follow me on
Instagram I'm gonna start doing a lot of
Instagram lives here's a link to my
Instagram I want to take some of those
1500 and add another 87 to 219 to your
Instagram list then I want you to do a
post on your Instagram that is literally
black and white with your phone number
and if you have to get a Google phone
number you do you know what a Google
Voice number is because you may not want
to give you away your actual number but
what I want you to do you know how
sometimes Dustin throw it up on the
bottom right now how I put out my phone
number I want you to post out on your
Instagram just a black and white with a
phone number
Google how to get a Google Voice number
get a voice number so you don't give
everybody in the world your number but I
want you to post and say I'm giving away
50 like literally the post is your phone
number and say please call to get a 15
minute consultation with me like I I
want you you need to become a better
Linda the reason you're not succeeding
is because you're not a good salesperson
I know that that's okay there's only
good news just like I wasn't eating well
and working out and that's why I wasn't
in the best shape that I could be and it
came super not natural to me me getting
better with my health is probably the
biggest accomplishment I've ever done
because it's the one accomplishment I've
done that - did not come natural to me
it also gave me the energy to give it
ice even more because now I saw that it
wasn't just DNA you need to become a way
better salesperson you know I think what
my challenge what that is because I've
been to so many like seminars where they
just sell from the stage and they have
like multiple speakers fuckability
that's [ __ ] but guess what that's
[ __ ] and I call that [ __ ] out all
the time guess what I've seen those two
I've been at some of those conferences
and gone in there and [ __ ] [ __ ] on
everybody that was there don't do that
yeah that's not selling selling is what
I do
believing in what you're selling and
doing it in a nice way where you just
ask not trick them with a funnel yeah
don't manipulate sell yeah those are two
very different things
witty I mean like Sam I mean what is
your definition like that like to me go
on go on go on go on
it's no selling is great when you
believe in it when I'm being serious not
to be the dead horse
I genuinely believe right this second
that anybody who buys wine in America is
better off signing up for wine texts and
buying anywhere else because I know the
business so well I know that text
message business buying is the best you
get a text you hit three enter and it
comes to your house it doesn't it makes
the amazon feel difficult I also know
that every wine that we text out is by
far the best price on that wine that
it's ever been sold at and it's
extremely high quality and it's the type
of wines that will expand people's
palates so I the reason I'm up here
pushing it so often is 90% cuz I love my
dad blindly but 10% because I just know
it's awesome
and if you really like the reason I
think everybody should hire Sasha the
Sasha group is cuz there's a lot of
people watching right now that you know
really could use it and it would be way
better than the agency or the internal
team they have the reason I don't push
that as often is because that's very
close to Gary the marketing man and I
don't want to kind of monetize my
audience and whereas the wine thing like
has nothing to do with anything other
than don't go to Trader Joe's or Publix
or total wine or BevMo and by gum [ __ ]
so if you if you actually believe the
part you set up front then you're the
best at it
that you're good at it I'm damn good
well then you need to get rid of that
insecurity that you come you're worried
about how you come off because you've
watched other people come off sleazy so
don't be [ __ ] sleazy and as a matter
of fact you're using a lot of their
sleazy tactics a free ebook a
consultation that's meant to be a funnel
how about a piece how about a piece of
content than just straightforward that
says you should [ __ ] use me I'm good
at what I do I'm 400 dollars an hour
like I'm being serious I don't hate by
the way on the record I don't hate a
free ebook and consultation but but we
can both agree that if you're worried
about the people that are on stage that
are sleazy those are those tactics yeah
so you've already succumbed to the
tactic mm-hmm the way here I can hear
you perfectly I can't hear me listen
listen like to me you just need it I
want to first make sure that you're
actually confident in what you're
selling I mean it in the subconscious
and then if that's not a problem which I
actually don't think it is with you
based on listening to you I just think
you need to do that or and stick with me
here find a way to afford somebody to be
the salesperson for you that's great
there's an unbelievable amount of people
watching right now everybody this is for
Instagram if you're a 15 year old 19
year old that you think you're great at
sales and you think you can spend the
month really getting to know her and
then be a salesperson for her and take a
20% Commission of every consultation she
gets you'll make a ton of money she'll
make a ton of money and two people will
be happy yeah I would love that yeah I
just I and one other quick question
because I've heard you like on say this
you know I I really want to do a lot in
my community it's you know I haven't
been here I've only been here for about
five years and and I was thinking of
doing like a podcast just for real
babies yes and women yes you should do
that yes comma I'm reading a lot of the
comments you're gonna get hit up by a
lot of people I see a lot of people
saying I can help Linda on the record I
don't want anybody talking to her that
can help her by selling your $400 sales
course you can only help her of one or
two ways free advice because you're a
good human or you'll you'll be
compensated as a salesperson for her
purely on commish
do not hit her up if you can help her by
selling your $1500 sales course thank
you you're you're loaded with doubt
around sales and by the way I'm loaded
with down around logistics I do not
trust myself to book my calendar or make
sure I'm going on the right plane or
make sure I'm in the right place which
is why I have admins at first I get it
and for years and years of my career
have admins or an admin so it took me a
long time to be able to afford it
luckily in sales I'm telling you right
now you're gonna hang up here and you
gonna start crying because you're gonna
have 55 DMS on your Instagram do you use
your Instagram enough to know where to
see your direct messages yes okay and I
promise you of those 55 six of them are
gonna say I'm willing to sell your
program just on commission and one of
those six is the right human for you and
you're both gonna make a lot of money
thank you Gary
you're welcome appreciate and I just I
did buy tickets for the all-in chow I
love that thank you I don't drink wine
but I did I just share it just sharing a
Facebook and I mean the world to me yeah
awesome thank you
greatly appreciate it thank you bye bye
all right we've got five minutes
see how hardcore my 11:00 is all right
let's sneak one more in oh my god it's
good man oh my god I can't believe I'm
here with you right now
where you from I'm from California West
Coast represent um I I couldn't sleep
today this morning like I woke up at
like 3:00 a.m. because I was just so
nervous and anxious and just came to be
here like you're my lifesaver man like
thank you I'm trying really hard not to
be emotional too but like I ran away
from home when I was 17 in and like you
know I look up to people like you and
and I'm here you know living by myself
from even though I'm not making a lot of
money
yeah I'm happier like my mind my money
[ __ ] but like
I love what I'm you know my passion like
I rather I love dancing and we do not
love it yeah
I'm just living a new life right yeah
that's right yes and you should and you
can afford a $35 [ __ ] Jordan hat so
you live it yeah I respect to the goat I
know who he is and I know what he means
anyway thank you what can I thank you
honestly like I'm just trying to do my
passion right now like I've been
documenting like what you say like
document my stuff like I just put up
freestyles on my Instagram I dance like
I I kind of like put stories for 597 I'm
just trying to figure out like how can I
make myself you know really just give
myself to to other people because I've
been working so hard to like to help
myself be you know like I've been
selfish about myself and not chasing
money or anything like that and really
now I just want to be able to inspire
people like hey you know you don't have
to really like you could be just happy
I'm good at home there are so many
people that they want to inspire people
inspiring people is very easy now it's
2020 you make videos right you put them
on tik-tok Facebook Instagram snapchat
yeah and you're you'll inspire someone
that's firing people is very different
than building an audience that you can
monetize so that you can be
self-sustaining for your life mhm
you know starting people you have a
crazy story you ran away from home
there's a lot underneath that you can
inspire a ton of people by telling real
stories and crying on YouTube and
Instagram and you'll [ __ ] do great
stuff I mean that brother you'll do
great stuff Alex I think I think
building a life of sustainability that
makes you happy is a different story I
love that you're testing out a final
fantasy videos can make you money are
you good enough I love that I love that
you're putting out beach or hip hop's or
things that nature it's so early and as
long as like look as long as it's super
tight with it afford the ability to do
your passion you got a really not you
got a real shot mm-hmm and that's what I
think that's one of the things I'm
struggling with as well is because um
I had this vicious cycle about okay I
hate work I hate working at a shitty job
so I'm gonna change my passion I [ __ ]
myself over excuse my language because I
don't have the money so why not get a
shitty job that looks one of two ways to
let you do your passion why not get a
shitty job at Gamestop so that you're
still in the culture mm-hmm video games
that might lead to serendipity that you
might meet somebody that comes in that
pops off for you or get a shitty job at
like 7-eleven where you can be on your
phone all day while you're at the
register cuz they're loose like that at
this one location shitty jobs are
amazing if you're strategic mm-hmm
there's two shitty jobs that everybody
should get when they need to the one
that just lets you work on your phone
all day cashier hostess and host step
you know like small business that just
doesn't give a [ __ ] as long as you do
the thing at all
you know got security guard you see
where I'm going or yeah or shitty job
within the culture that you want I hear
Final Fantasy I'm like yo go be an
intern at ei yo go be an intern at you
know Activision yo go work $11 an hour
at [ __ ] game stop because a [ __ ]
YouTube influencer might come in and
become your boy or your girl and [ __ ]
puts you on shitty jobs strategically or
the [ __ ] game and are about to become
the game for the 30 plus million
Americans that need a [ __ ] job this
is gonna be maybe an important clip for
me there's a shitty job strategy that's
gonna really matter and I just laid it
out in one of two ways in the game that
you want to be in so that 78 comes or so
loose that you can [ __ ] build your
life here while you're getting your 9
bucks an hour shitty job strategy bro
shitty job strategy you see they're
going yeah yeah like right now a shitty
job yeah right now I got like I just
recently got hired on to goodwill but
because it's because because the krona
like I I'm like I only work this from
one day and I'm quarantined and I'm on
unpaid furlough so I'm just trying
you got lucky bro you snuck that yeah I
got [ __ ] lucky oh my god I mean
I know everybody's lucky but you [ __ ]
on the business on the job front you
[ __ ] gratitude the [ __ ] out of that
honestly I feel so [ __ ] lucky because
I'm grateful that I rent I pay only $400
for rent like I have amazing landlord
like he he forgave my rent for this
month because of what the hell's going
on in all this [ __ ] like we have a
really great relationship and I'm just
so grateful like I've been through so
much [ __ ] and I'm just so happy that I'm
at a good spot where I can actually
start the life that I want to be like
the person that I you're gonna be you
already did the hardest part running
ways impossible that's a mental battle
it's easy to pack your [ __ ] walk out the
door that mental warfare is incredible
you have so much strength Thank You ru
so much thank you it
welcome house you sell that Jordan hat
on Facebook marketplace 426 I'll have
even more you know good I'll talk to my
landlord it's funny because I also did
did some thrift store stuff to like I
like I I remember going down to go down
to Irvine or like I another good well
before I worked at Goodwill and like I
bought like dude this was the craziest
story alright I bought a rocket racoon
and like I got for two bucks at a
goodwill a stuffed animal one yeah stuff
animal rocket racoon yep and I sold that
[ __ ] for 30 bucks because they was
selling like hotcakes for 32 dollars on
eBay
Alex but it looks Alex I gave you the
shitty job strategy the greatest
strategy in my opinion is goodwill
garage sales flea markets flip like I
can't explain enough to people that make
minimum wage how they'll make more money
and have more fun doing the flip life
right I think the hardest part for me is
my car cuz my car bro have have humility
get on the bus and go to Goodwill and
then get on the bus again
mmm when my mom came to this country
used to walk mom how far was [ __ ]
Kmart from the house oh she's in her
headphones here she comes ha ha ha watch
this
yeah
for my mom she's watching over it in the
corner mom mom how far did we walk to
Kmart when we came to America we still
look five [ __ ] miles to Kmart and
back damn because it was no fun voice
cuz we didn't have a car because my mom
and by the way I was [ __ ] lazy I
didn't like that one my mom I used to
jump up my mom's shoulders she had to
drag my ass my little sister was younger
she was cool but like I I couldn't do it
so like you know yeah like five miles
like why can't you of course it sounds
crazy but when your timing work [ __ ]
when your alternative is getting into 7
12 9 bucks how much you get paid a
goodwill bring it down for me uh twelve
thirteen dollars right Goodwill when
you're when you're [ __ ] getting paid
$13 free you know all the [ __ ] that
comes out of it you know like your time
is not worth that much all of a sudden
were walking 2 hours doesn't seem so
crazy and definitely taking bus doesn't
seem crazy
yeah I've taken the bus you know what
I'm saying you know what else does that
sound crazy making a social media post
saying yo does anybody have a car that's
willing to drive me around I'll pay for
your gas and I'll give you five percent
of what I sell oh now we've got the
whole ideas that flip the switch people
always got an excuse I've always got a
[ __ ] answer the answer is humility
and creativity okay gotcha what do you
think a straight yo I will teach you
anybody got a car that I'll [ __ ] anybody
out there got a shitty job that with a
car I'll teach you the flip life you
drive me around you see where I'm going
I got a friend yeah [ __ ] oh yeah
that's optimism humility creativity
these are the [ __ ] games mmm that's
what I think I need to be more
optimistic about my life then yeah cause
like the reason I like using acronyms
like huge I'm gonna call it the
choo-choo theory right creativity
humility optimism offense creativity
humility optimism office
choo choo [ __ ] definitely I
agree with that
so oh yeah I love you brother
thank you
thank you I'm killing it with the
acronyms give me something for that one
Dustin
that was [ __ ] on-the-fly quick give
me I know you [ __ ] love the choo-choo
Theory bro hmm I could see the Instagram
post already with the default [ __ ]
train emoji I [ __ ] got this choo choo
[ __ ] yeah people can do this
thank you all for watching so much the
all-in challenge I've got a crazy offer
on the all-in challenge $10 Rob raffle
tickets you buy a 20 pack for a hundred
bucks so it's 5 $5 raffle tickets and
I'm giving away something crazy I'm
giving away this I am giving away the
ultimate garyvee experience how should I
go okay over the last week or so I've
been a gem with my friend Michael Rubin
and helping out on this all-in challenge
that I am accepting right now but all-in
challenge calm please go there we are
challenging some of the greatest artists
entertainers athletes in the world to
provide a ridiculous all-time experience
or one of their most iconic items in
their collection to help raise money to
help feed the hungry during this
ridiculous time and so now I have to put
up my auction so my auction the ultimate
garyvee experience here we go we've gone
off the top of the head I didn't go on
all-in challenge calm to go bid on this
I am giving away okay you get to in the
course of the year you will go garage
sailing with me and film trash talk also
you can get a workout with me and Micah
Conti so I know a lot of you pay
attention to that part of my world also
we're gonna go to Wine Library and do a
$25,000 shopping spree that's right I'm
gonna pay my dad well I'm gonna donate
we're gonna pay my dad 25,000 so $25,000
shopping spree at Wine Library I will
walk through the whole store with you
tell you the war stories and you'll buy
a bunch of wine beer liquor whatever you
want food we are going to go to a Jets
game together
you're gonna tailgate with me I never do
this when I give away Jets tickets I
never let the person sit with me so you
will sit with me during the Jets game I
won't talk to you during the game I'm
completely focused but you'll get that
so the ultimate Jets experience tailgate
full game with me as well also I'm going
to give you one week play
Vayner media so this is for you in a
plus one by the way so the two tickets
the four will do some plus ones will do
some just me and you depending on this
one full week at vaynermedia getting
consulting a business advice from team
Gary B and me for the entire week
hanging out in the pit where the shows
done you're gonna be a guest of my
podcast we're gonna do a wine dinner for
you and seven of your friends at Hunt
fish club in New York City and I'm gonna
fly you all paid plus 1 to 3 of my
keynotes and we'll work on those details
the ultimate garyvee experience I hope
you bid on it I hope you get involved I
hope we raise a lot of money to help
people that need it all so what's so fun
about the Olin challenge is you get to
challenge people to be in it I am gonna
challenge all the banner sports athletes
I expect you in there so that is number
one number two I'm gonna go with ooh you
know what
Tim Berlin the super producer who's
completely lighting up Instagram
Timbaland the super producer I'm calling
you out and finally I got one the
Undertaker
one of the great wrestlers of all time
please join the challenge everybody go
to all in challenge calm please support
this the experiences are gonna be nuts
we've been working bleeding out of the
eyeballs for the last week putting this
all together you're gonna be blown away
what you're about to see on social media
hashtag all and challenge please check
it out and please go to your favorite
celebrities athletes and entertainers
and leave hash tag all and challenge to
get them involved the all and challenge
please take it